so um thinking about machine learning
and economics or machine learning and
econometrics or machine learning and
social science
um we can start by by saying you know
what what are we talking about here with
machine learning
um there's two big types of machine
learning there's actually lots of types
of machine learning
um beyond this like reinforcement
learning and different parts of ai
uh but two two really big types for
distinguishing
uh for what the comments i'm gonna make
today are between supervised and
unsupervised machine learning
so unsupervised machine learning is like
when you have when you have a bunch of
videos or you have a bunch of pictures
or a bunch of documents
and there's no labels on them nobody has
said that's a cat that's a dog
to start with your input is just a bunch
of objects
and what you're trying to do is put
those into groups that are similar in
some way
so they might be um you know images and
then
when you put them into groups you look
at group number 5 4 5476
and that group when you open up all the
images in that group you see that
they're all cats
so then you'd say ah my machine learning
algorithm discovered cats
what it what it actually did is it put a
bunch of images together that it thought
were similar and then later on
you looked at it and you said ah that
looks like cats but you didn't tell
the algorithm that cats existed or that
there was any specific reason to be
looking for cats that's just
something that discovered it was
discovered um
there's little difference across
disciplines with how these methods
are used or what their purpose is
they're generally
an a first step towards something else
that something else can differ uh it
could be that you know you're
you're going to use it as an explanatory
variable and a regression or it could be
you're going to use it to describe
features of products
um there's many different things you
might do with it afterwards
but when it's done in this kind of
isolated way
i feel like if you want to learn how to
do this you can just
google it find some great videos find
something on coursera
and if you're a social scientist you can
just apply the methods
and i don't have anything new to say to
you about
how to do them they're they're going to
be similar
um i would say that you know political
science has used
text quite a bit and so some methods
will get more popular in some discipline
than others but fundamentally there's
not a difference in the goals
um the place where it's things get i
think a little bit more interesting
or where things that seem alike actually
turn out to be different
is in supervised machine learning which
is the thing that
sort of looks like running regressions
which is something that we do a lot of
in the social sciences and we teach a
lot of an econometrics class
so in supervised learning you start with
a setting where there's independent
observations and a stable environment
so you know each observation is
exchangeable with another observation
um and uh and and
in the simplest case you know there's no
correlation between them so
uh a regression problem that we all
teach in first year econometrics we're
we're trying to build a model
of the x the conditional mean the
expectation of y as a function of x
and supervised machine learning is also
about predicting y
as a function of x so those basically
look like
the same thing and classification
where in this case y would be discrete
so why is maybe a label like is it a cat
a dog or a horse
um that's trying to understand
you know which label is most appropriate
given x's that looks like a multinomial
logistic regression
which is also something that we teach
and study and use a lot in social
sciences
so it looks like supervised machine
learning is the same thing as what we do
in social sciences and to make them seem
even more similar
when you take a machine learning course
probably the first
prediction model you learn is regression
and probably the first classification
model you learn is
you know logistic regression so this all
sounds like we're solving exactly the
same
problem but then what's kind of funny
about it is that we do
these things differently and so i want
to kind of talk to you a little bit
about
why we approach that same problem in
different ways and actually
why it's meaningful to ask different
questions from those same
um those same methods so
just to start with though let's kind of
take a look at an example of
classification of
one of the most common problems that's
been studied in machine learning and one
of the biggest successes
from the last 15 years is our
improvement in the ability to solve
classification problems
so typical classification problem is you
know you have a bunch of pictures
um say pictures of of animals these
pictures you downloaded from
from the web and what you're trying to
do
is to uh classify them so
that you would you in in the
classification problem
you're starting with a training data set
where
um there you have images and there
you have labels so people have in your
training data set the data set you're
using to estimate your model
you have labels the y's like cat dog
course and you have the pictures um
in order to build this classification
model there's some processing you have
to do
so first of all you have to translate
the image into
observable characteristics of the image
and just a simple way to think about
that is like on your computer screen
you're staring at right now
um you can make an image of me talking
to you or my slides
using you know red green blue and the
brightness
of each of those colors and that
together
will create an image so that's one way
you can translate an image
just into you know bits and bytes
they're they're the
pixels each of the pixels um and then
for for red green blue how bright they
are and now i've got a
digital description of the image um then
i want to put that into a model
and and and classify you know given x as
this a cat
now already there's a little bit of a
gap because uh
in in some machine learning applications
you're not actually trying to build a
model
that gives a probability of a cat you're
just
want to say is it a cat so
when these algorithms work in production
they're not necessarily spitting out a
probability they might be
they might not be they might just be
spitting out cat dog cat dog
and it might actually take additional
computation for it to spit out
a probability well if we were studying
this problem
in economics we would be
building a logistic regression and try
and and trying to use that
to come up with a probability and
actually
the way that we use the regression in
economics
would typically be that we would be
interested in the coefficients we would
be interested in the function itself
and we would be trying to understand if
i changed something
if i changed an x how would that change
the probability
so we would be really trying to
understand the model
rather than just spit out is it a cat or
is it a dog
um now one of the so some of the big
advances for images neural nets turned
out to work really well
and you know who who knew that that
would be the case but they are a very
rich functional form
and so what what the advances in machine
learning have been all about
is figuring out how to how to solve this
hard problem where you have all these
bits in that are representing pixels
and i'm going to somehow get a
meaningful prediction out of that and
the neural nets
can be thought of as a very flexible
functional form um to do that
so here's an example of like why machine
learning is great
uh this is a a marketing brochure for
mckenzie
and so uh in this marketing brochure the
problem was to predict which customers
would
would churn and that means to abandon a
service
and we have on the x-axis and
axis of this we have two drivers of
churn and you can imagine that might be
you know how often you've logged into
the website or
um some other uh behavior it could be a
characteristic of a person
so these are the the x variables that
could be used to predict churn
and so the mckinsey is in this picture
contrasting
a churn model based on a simple
old-fashioned
logistic regression so in the logistic
regression
they're they're they've got a binary
outcome
churn or no churn and they have these
characteristics of the consumers
and they're using those characteristics
to predict churn and this nice smooth
green line
is the iso probability line for um
so everybody along all the the driver's
a driver's b pairs along that line
have the same probability of churn and
so
mckinsey is pointing out that in these
hand-tuned simple
uh functional forms that people would
write down by hand
you would have a very simple
relationship um between
uh drivers a and drivers b in terms of
predicting
churn now all these fancy hills and
valleys are what come out of the machine
learning model
so and i'm going to assume that mckinsey
ran the software correctly
and so that mckenzie's model did a
better job classifying
churn than the simple logistic
regression model
um so that's good and let's assume
that's true and then we can also assume
that it's true that this kind of
complicated relationship between a and b
in terms of prediction
was actually better at predicting
outcomes in a test set
let's imagine that's true but how would
you do as a social
scientist or even as a business person
trying to use this output
to make decisions so if you took this
literally if you held drivers a
a at 80 an increased driver's b what
this model
seems to be telling you if you interpret
it that way is that if you held driver's
a
fixed and you increase drivers b that
the probability of churn
would go up and then down and up and
then down and up and then down
so you have all these hills and valleys
in the probability
so if you if you went out and tried to
think about making decisions based on
that
um you might get some counter-intuitive
results and it might not be the best
guide
about you know which customers to to
recruit
um and and
it might also not be that convincing on
mechanisms
so you think why is that well part of
the thing is the goal of a
predictive model is just to predict it
was estimated
and trained the shape of the functional
form was all about just getting the y
right getting the best prediction of
whether you're going to churn or not and
that's different
from a causal analysis where
i might want to say well what what if b
is something i can affect like what if i
could get people to log into the website
more
well would i want to try to get people
to log in the website more do i think
that would actually cause them to churn
less
that's a very different question and you
would estimate the model very
differently
to answer that question and so one of
the insights and the
the recorded lectures we'll go into much
more detail about is
you know when you could or couldn't
interpret uh
a model in terms of uh
in terms of causality in terms of what
you might want to manipulate or even in
terms of who you might want to target
for something
and so there's there's different
objectives for different kinds of
questions and actually your estimation
techniques should differ depending on
the question you're asking
to think about this another way we could
use this model to try to predict
um who should we call who should we who
should get a phone call
um now the mckinsey model is going to be
very good
at figuring out who's likely to quit but
maybe some of those people are
are quitting your service because they
graduated and they're moving away
maybe they're graduating from stanford
and they're going to
move to a different country or they're
going to move to a different city
so calling people who are going to move
away is not going to be very beneficial
for uh for a company
so that's looking at a higher level if
you were trying to
use a prediction model predicting who's
going to quit isn't the same as finding
the people
for whom you should intervene those are
different questions and you would use
different models to answer them
um so that's that's really going to be
one
one set of themes that we're going to
want you to learn from this class
if you go to an econometrics class
they're going to assume
you're trying to understand you know
what happens if i hold
everything fixed and i change one
variable because that's one of the ways
we think about regression
um well if you go to machine learning
class they're going to assume that you
want to predict
or you want to classify and so the the
the
the objectives are actually uh different
um machine learning is great it can fit
these complex shapes so my friend
who was at microsoft made this uh
goodness of fit for clippy the paperclip
who was microsoft's first ai and clippy
didn't work very well
sadly it was not a very good ai but we
can use ai to fit clippy's shape
and finally you know 15 or 20 years
later um we actually
have help assistants that actually do
help us unlike a poor little clippy who
was um
made fun of so um
just to then to put a little more
structure on the comments i made earlier
and again this will be elaborated on
further in the
additional recorded lectures this week
but when we think about prediction
the goal of prediction is going to be to
estimate
a single number what is my for if it's y
what is my best prediction of y um
and i'm going to do that to try to
minimize the mean squared error
in a new data set where only x is
observed so the the stated problem of
machine learning is that i have a data
set with y's and x's
i build a model if you give me new x's
i can predict it i can predict what the
y will be
so if you think about it from a
professor's perspective
i could hire a research assistant give
them some x's and y's and tell them to
go back and build a model
and then in my office i'm going to hide
some data and i know the x's and i don't
know the y's
when the research assistant comes back
i'll see i'll give them the x's
and i'll test them on how well they can
predict the ys
and all i need to know i don't need to
know how the research assistant did it i
don't care if they built a neural net or
a random forest or something else
i just care that i'm gonna i'm gonna
just give you a pop quiz i'm gonna feed
in the x's and you're gonna tell me the
y's and i'm gonna score you
just based on those y's nothing else
okay and so the machine learning problem
is actually
then a sort of a simple problem because
i don't care what you did or why it
works
i just care that it works and if my the
actual
way i want to use the model is again to
give it more x's and have it predict
more wise
all i care is that it works so it's kind
of machine learning you can think of as
like a robotic research assistant
you know i used to go tell my research
assistant to run 100 regressions
now i've got a robotic research
assistant and they're going to run a
billion regressions
and they're going to come back with the
best one and i'll be able to tell right
away if they did a good job
okay so that's that's what machine
learning is good at
um now there's some details like
it turns out that minimizing mean
squared error is going to actually
entail a bias variance trade-off and
it's always going to
accept some bias so that's a different
objective than trying to get
an unbiased estimate of the conditional
mean function
the idea of how this machine learning
algorithms work is you consider a family
of models
and you use the data to select among the
models um
and the common approach is
cross-validation so it's like
to prepare for your big test you pretend
that you're studying for a test
you hide some of the data from yourself
and see how well you do
and so then you you you you give
yourself a bunch of pop quizzes
pretending simulating the scenario that
you will later face in my office
and you find the thing that does best in
your little pop quizzes that you're
giving to yourself where you hide some
data from yourself
you figure out the thing that works best
once you've got that all sorted out then
you come to my office
and i give you the final test and and
and see how well you did
but if you if you practiced well and
simulated the testing environment
you will probably have found something
that will also work well
um in in the test set that i hid from
you
um and machine learning basically works
well because you can
accurately evaluate performance without
a lot of additional assumptions
all you have to see is how well it fits
because its only goal is to fit
um you don't have to argue about
additional assumptions
you know you could argue about whether
the environment you're going to apply it
in is actually stable maybe it's going
to change over time
there's a few things to argue about and
of course you can
argue a lot about whether the algorithms
are fair or biased or have some
societal implication but just
do they work not much to argue about
um so let me now i'm going to do a
little bit of provocative
discussion here and i should say i am i
consider myself a machine learning
person so i
i can make fun of both economists and
machine learning because i publish in
both
journals and go to both conferences so
i'm gonna i can make fun of uh
both sides when i say what do we say
versus what do we do coming from the
machine learning perspective
machine learning basically says machine
learning is everything
and actually we probably invented it i
think right nobody ever did anything
before machine learning was a thing
uh so i've i've been told many times by
uh by machine learning folks that if
economists
had had anything to say about how i use
data somebody would have told me
it would have showed up in my machine
learning class you know and i've been
asked even do economists use data
i i thought they did theory so
there's a little bit of a lack of
appreciation for the fact that many
disciplines
you know political science and economics
and and you know
biostatistics and so on have been
grappling with uh statistical problems
for decades
and even centuries and have
had some ideas along the way that are
helpful for solving certain kinds of
problems
uh machine learning often though will
use the language of answering questions
or solving problems
even when they are not answering
questions or solving problems
so it's very common and i see this a lot
with startups a startup will come to me
and say
i have software for prioritizing
customers
like the churn example i gave i have
software that will help you prioritize
which people should get a sales call
to prevent them from churning i'd say
great
uh let's see your prioritization
software
and what they'll show me as a model for
predicting churn
but again as we previously discussed
being able to predict who's going to
quit is not the same
as determining who should your sales
people call
half the people the people who are most
predictably going to quit might be
people who are moving away and are not
at all affected by a sales call
so they'll say i've got this great ai
algorithm that will prioritize your
consumers for you
but in fact this great ai algorithm is
actually just
prediction and it's predicting the wrong
thing
it's not predicting the thing you would
want for prioritization
now it could be helpful for
prioritization because certainly
predicting people who are not going to
quit
means those people probably shouldn't
get a sales call but among the people
who might quit
you need something else to figure out
who should you actually call
who for whom would a call be effective
that's a causal question
and so people in social sciences are
very used to thinking about well gee do
you even have data that could possibly
answer that question that's we spend
tons of time thinking about
is your question even answerable and
that's not
the type of thinking that you're taught
in a basic machine learning class you
just assume every question is answerable
um and you just need good algorithms um
add a few layers to your neural net and
i'm sure the problem is now solvable
that's kind of the the mentality that
you get um
from you know especially introductory or
basic machine learning
um so basically what we say is we can do
everything
um and we've solved most problems we
have a great hammer and everything is a
nail
and that's sort of true like from a as a
general purpose technology like
prediction is incredibly applicable
and you can have the same algorithms
that can be used across lots of domains
so that's actually really important for
economics actually like big picture
economics like
it's a general purpose technology and it
can be used really widely and we can
make algorithms open source and they can
affect a lot of the world so i
i'm a big believer in that and i give
entire lectures on that
but it's not true that just off the
shelf that every question
is best answered using just those tools
and that's where there's a big
divergence between
social sciences and machine learning so
generally what machine learning people
actually do is they use predictive
models they ignore other questions
whether it's causality
equilibrium feedback effects and then
they have
you know little conferences or subfields
that sit around and wonder or worry
about interpretability reliably
robustness
fairness um but they have little ways to
ask algorithms to optimize for it and a
lot of times a lot of the
the literature on fairness is is is
viewed as like an x-post thing i'm going
to
verify that my algorithms are fair or
i'm going to put constraints on them
rather than actually completely changing
the way you think about them
um and which would be i think more of a
social science approach
um so traditional econometrics
economists often focus on the case with
a lot more observations and covariates
every one of you who made it through
your first year econometrics or
courses had to probably memorize the
proof for your final exam
that ols is blue i still have the little
sticky note sticking out of my
econometrics textbook for the page of
the with the proof for ols is blue
so what does that mean for those of you
who haven't had to take that final exam
that means that ordinary least squares
is the best
linear unbiased estimator of the
coefficients
of a of a linear prediction model
okay so ordinarily squares is trying to
be unbiased
now when i i studied that proof and
dutifully passed my exams and
uh you know got an a uh without ever
really
contemplating deeply why i wanted things
to be unbiased
the way it was presented it was just of
course that's what you want
um why would you want anything else why
would you want something biased
whereas in machine learning when you're
trying to do
prediction in a test set with a model
that might be very rich relative to the
size of your data set
you explicitly allow for bias because
there's a bias variance trade-off and
predictions
and and the the lectures this week will
go into that in substantially more
detail um but to start to even see where
that breaks apart you know
if you have more more parameters and you
have observations it's obvious
that uh ols is not going to be good at
anything it's going to be over fit
economists and instead worry about
estimating causal effects and what's
called identification
identification means if i had an
infinite amount of data
could i answer my question and just to
think of an example where you might not
be able to
um consider the problem of hotels so
uh a a causal question about hotels
might be
if i raise the price of my hotels
how many more how many customers will i
lose
that's a business question and it's
something that we study a lot in
economics and in marketing
what happens if i change a price now i
might go out and collect data
i could collect data i could have
somebody i could scrape
prices from you know hotels.com or
something like that i could figure out
what prices were
and i could hire a research assistant to
stand outside a hotel
and count the people coming in and out
you know once a week or something like
that
right so then i could put together a
data set that had quantities and prices
in it
okay and then i could try to build some
kind of a model
i could run a regression price you know
quantities on the left side prices on
the right side
now what would the coefficient be on
prices in that regression
well if you if you ever have gone to a
conference or stayed in a hotel
uh had a school vacation you would
probably realize that
actually when the prices are high
for the hotel it's probably full
so you would get a positive coefficient
in that regression high prices
high quantities and indeed if your goal
was prediction suppose i just
my goal was for some reason i wanted to
guess how many people were in the hotel
on a particular day high prices is a
great signal that that hotel is full
from a predictive perspective high
prices predict
high quantities that's that's a fact
true in the data absolutely true and by
the way this is true for a lot of data
sets economy this is why economists
started worrying about this
because in many data sets prices and
quantities are actually positively
correlated
um so why what's where's the the
the breakdown here well the causal
question is what if i hold everything
fixed and i change the price
and but your date you never had in your
data a chance where somebody ran an
experiment on prices
if you did you don't you may not know
about it in your data and so
in your data the variation is coming
from holidays
and um conferences and
you know too many weddings that weekend
other things
that increase both demand and supply
and thus uh your that induces this
correlation and the data between prices
and quantities
but that doesn't mean if you intervene
and raise price that you will
um sell more hotel rooms so
economists think about that all the time
and they might if they end up finding a
way to figure out
how to um estimate this relationship
it's probably true that their predictive
model would have very low explanatory
power
because the biggest thing for pred for
predicting quantities is knowing the
price high prices high quantities if
you're trying to predict
that's going to explain most things but
if you're looking for
natural experiments in price where price
change for a reason that didn't have to
do with a holiday
it's you're probably not going to have
very many of those price changes and
you're not going to have a very good
ability to predict
quantities but you will learn more about
what happens when you change price
and that's what what economists and
social scientists really focus on
counter factual predictions separating
correlation from causality
we also obsess on standard errors uh
because it's actually really hard to
learn causal effects
and it's very common that something you
find is actually
not that well pinned down and your
coefficients could be due to sampling
variation so causal effects
we spend a lot of time worrying about
sampling variation
it's also the case that it's very hard
to tell if you got the right answer
uh because it depends so you you you
really want theory to be playing a role
and you want to think about the
statistical properties of your
estimators
um so those are things economists worry
about
and we also are very aware that
identification problems can't be
evaluated just using
a holdout set so if prices and
quantities are
positively correlated in my whole data
set if i take a random sample
prices and quantities will also be
positively correlated in my test set
and i'm not going to figure out from a
test set that i misunderstood
why prices and quantities were
positively correlated the test side
isn't going to do that
and some of my research and i'll talk
about this at the end we
we construct very specially constructed
test sets that can actually help you
understand whether you got the answer
right um but it
it's not just a random sample of the
data that's going to fix your problem
for you
so of course i can also make fun of
econometrics what we say versus what we
do
what we say is that we do causal
inference in counterfactuals
we think about the data generating
process and we say
the god of economics gave us the model
you know
and we pretend that we just estimated
one model
we say you know the god of economics
told me that log of wages depends on
the log of something else and something
else squared and something else cubed
now and we then report causal estimates
and appropriate standard errors
plus a few additional specifications for
robustness
now what we actually do is we go and
tell our research assistants to run 100
different specifications
just to make sure it doesn't change our
results and then we kind of pick
five representative ones and we show
them and we produce them as if we hadn't
done that at all
now it's not that we're all bad people i
mean
maybe we are but uh that's not it's not
necessarily true that we're all bad
people
for doing it that way um instead
we're uh we're working with what we have
if you like
and we're we didn't really have a good
way to try to do this robustness
systematically and of course you don't
want to publish a result which goes away
if you add in a cubic term
so you want to be sure that you're
you're accurately representing
the way the world works because people
are going to use your results for policy
so what one of the things that machine
learning can do is it can take us out of
that conundrum
it can give us a way to do robustness
systematically fully describe honestly
what we did
and still be able to report results
about the parameters we care about
and that's going to be one of the things
we'll teach about in this course how we
do that
um how we get rid of that very
uncomfortable unpleasant and unreliable
part of research where we just run a
bunch of specifications
and hope we've been comprehensive enough
and hope we haven't been so
comprehensive that we've screwed up
and and gone data phishing for our for
our
um favorite result um
so some key lessons for econometrics um
many problems can be
decomposed into predictive and causal
parts and one of the things we're going
to show is that once you do that
decomposition
then you can use off-the-shelf machine
learning for some of the predictive
parts
we also want to learn from machine
learning how to do data driven model
selection
but we want to do it a little
differently we want to be tailored to
our econometric goals tailored to
parameter estimation
and there's some insights things like
you know
crossfitting um that that come up once
we once we tailor our estimation
for our goal and we also might use
different
optimization criteria different
objective functions depending on our
goal
and we want it but we we're going to so
we're going to modify things in a way
that optimizes for a specific objective
like parameter estimation
and retains the ability to do inference
machine learning uh inspired approaches
for robustness
another thing we can learn um validation
machine learning always has a test set
um i've worked on some of my historical
research
about auctions had that kind of setting
where i had two different auction models
and i estimated using one auction
game and predicted in another auction
game but that's been relatively rare in
economics and so one of the things that
i've been working on in my own work is
how to come up with clever ways to
what types of data sets to look at and
ways to define test sets that help us
assess better
whether we've done a good job with
counter factuals and i've some of that's
in supermarket data where we have lots
of price changes
we've also can learn other computational
approaches
even for structural models things like
stochastic gradient descent or really
powerful
computational techniques that can unlock
a lot of performance
um in in
in structural models and i'll talk more
about at the end of the course
so prediction in five years um a lot of
these techniques will be
uh standard in social sciences and
honestly
they they already are becoming a
standard they're becoming a requirement
not an option
um regularization and data-driven model
selection will be
standard prediction problems problems
the part where you really do just care
about a prediction it will be better
appreciated and better delineated from
causal models
measurement using machine learning
techniques might be an important
subfield
textual analysis will get bigger and
again it's already very big
in some parts of economics and political
science we'll
be better and more careful about
explicitly distinguishing causal parts
and predictive parts of models
um and then we'll delegate the parts
that are more predictive to
machine learning and data driven fit
we're going to have reduced emphasis on
sampling variation
and more on model robustness and we may
consider models with lots of latent
variables or factor models
more commonly for uh for panel data or
different types of data structures there
are not just you know
single shot independent observations
okay